bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur un terreau france saint denis
est également touchée par ces tensions
quelle est la situation dans votre ville
et écouter effectivement il ya eu
quelques émeutes dans beaucoup de villes
de france dont saint denis mais qui
n'est pas particulièrement touché par
les émeutes pour l'instant mais je pense
que ces émeutes
elles ont un sens elles ont un sens et
encore plus pendant le pendant le
confinement et je pense que les
personnes qui montre du doigt les
quartiers comme étant des zones de
non-droit devraient plutôt réfléchir à
une chose c'est que deux danseurs dans
ces quartiers-là la république a déserté
depuis très longtemps et que les
inégalités sociales qui existait dans
les quartiers populaires se sont
exacerbées en fait ont été exacerbées
par la crise sanitaire et pour se rendre
compte d'une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y avait pas d élan solidaire et
associatifs des enfants ne pourraient
pas manger à leur faim dans les
quartiers populaires celles que l'état a
complètement abandonné un pan de la
population aujourd'hui est ce qu'on a vu
comme émeutes depuis quelques jours
suite à une énième violence policière
qui a eu lieu à villeneuve la garenne
rappelle que depuis le confinement
ces sept plaintes qui ont été déposées
c'est des personnes qui ont été
violentés par la police un peu partout
en ile de france et notre héros est
aussi à saint pierre des corps donc il
faut poser la question de l'impunité de
la polique pis il faut poser la question
des quartiers populaires comme boucs
émissaires de la crise sanitaire mais se
rendre compte d'une chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la situation dans les
quartiers n'est plus tenable
aujourd'hui la seule forme d'état que
les gens voient dans les quartiers c'est
la police au début du confinement 10%
des amendes été mise en scène samedi
donc c'est pas possible en fait de gérer
les quartiers populaires comme on gérait
un zoo ou une bande de personnes
incontrôlable il y a des choses qui se
font dans les quartiers qui ne se font
pas dans les autres villes de france
désolant solidaires qu'on ne verra pas
ailleurs pour autant l'état déserté les
postes sont quasiment toutes fermées les
services publiques classiques ont
déserté depuis longtemps on impose
aujourd'hui de réouverture le 11 mai
alors qu'on sait que depuis très
longtemps les moyens ne sont pas
suffisants
de la part de l'état pour l'éducation
nationale donc oui ces émeutes sont un
révélateur
un vrai prédateur du ras-le-bol et puis
une chose que les gens ne mentionne
jamais c'est que le confinement est
beaucoup plus facile à respecter dans le
7e arrondissement paris quand on a noté
particulier qu'en seine saint denis ou
ailleurs quand on a un logement
insalubre où un seul logement qui est
sûre occupée donc il faut tenir compte
de ces de ses particularismes là et
prendre les choses avec un peu de ne
reculer considérer que ce qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui c'est un ras-le-bol sociale
sur fond de crise sanitaire
parce que on sait une chose nous
habitants des quartiers populaires nous
on sait de quoi on parle on est
quasiment certain que l'état ne changera
pas de politique
après la crise sanitaire on repartira
avec les mêmes séries gassion sociales
et spatiales avec les mêmes
stigmatisation des quartiers populaires
avec le même manque de moyens à saint
denis par exemple on annonce quand même
des fermetures d'écoles à la rentrée
donc ils ne prennent aucun compte de ce
qui se passe et des remontées terrain de
la part des acteurs et des élus donc oui
sur cette situation en cours ces
derniers jours dans certains quartiers
de la proche banlieue parisienne on
entend très peu christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur comment est-ce
que vous l'interprétez et qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire à court terme selon
vous pour un baiser le climat certains
évoquent l'instauration d'un couvre-feu
l'envoi de l'armée est ce que c'est la
solution quel est votre regard ans
fauchée sur ses solutions évoquées par
certains
si on veut une section vu qu'il ya un
regain de violence alors oui et métaux
encombre au feu et envoyons l'armée non
on peut pas gérer les quartiers
populaires comme si c'était des zones
hors de la france
encore une fois je les dis au début de
mon propos il n'y a pas de territoires
perdus de la république il n'y a que des
territoires abandonnés par la république
et christophe castaner le sait très bien
il sait très bien qu'il y à un culte de
l'impunité de la police dont beaucoup
dans beaucoup de quartiers les violences
policières sont rarement punis quand
elles sont réellement poursuivis lundi
gipn a tardé a été obligé d'ouvrir une
enquête suite à la plainte du jeune
homme de villeneuve la garenne sinon du
gpn ne serait pas saisie d' enquête
parce que c'est un commissaire qui est
mien qui est mis en cause
tout ça les gens des quartiers
populaires le savent sans parler de la
situation dans les hôpitaux ils servent
qu'à une soeur morte surmortalité parce
que c'est un désert médical plus
qu'ailleurs dont christophe castaner
sait très bien que c'est l'échec de ses
politiques
que c'est l'échec du tout répressif et
que ce dont on a besoin d'eux les
quartiers populaires avant de nous
mettre des policiers partout c'est de
nous mettre davantage d'états davantage
de moyens
davantage de respect dignité aussi et
aujourd'hui on est très très loin du
compte donc le silence de musique
castaner ne me surprend pas mais en tout
état de cause si des gens sont tentés
par un volet répressif
je pense que il ne mesure pas la gravité
de leur potentiel at il faut encore une
fois traitées les quartiers populaires
avec respect merci pour votre regard
madjid messaoudene je rappelle que vous
êtes conseiller municipal de saint denis